a large number of migrants are
headed to the united states right now
this is
often the case but they're headed there
in higher numbers than usual
they're approaching california and
they're wearing joe biden t-shirts
not joking there's a photograph of a
group of
migrants heading toward america wearing
t-shirts that say biden
please let us in biden please let us in
raises a few questions one
if these migrants are able to get these
nice brand spank and new t-shirts they
see you know really good
one it means this is not just some
randomly you know grassroots springing
effort
of people who are destitute just seeking
survival even you know as we're always
told that refugees who are going to be
killed in their home countries and
that's why we need to let them into the
united states
no this is pretty well organized they
have access to
a decent number of resources somebody
is obviously organizing them
someone with a political agenda and
they're
i don't something tells me they're not
here fleeing the marauders or the
political persecutors in their home
countries right they seem
they're they're just kind of calmly
walking through mexico walking up to the
united states
they're obviously economic migrants who
are seeking
they actually are seeking a better life
for for their children and their
families there's no question about that
i'd rather live in america than i would
in mexico or guatemala or something like
that
but the situation is not what the
democrats are telling us democrats are
telling us this is about just
life and death and no it's not it's
about people
making more money and having more
opportunity for their kids okay i
understand that
so that's why we have a nice immigration
policy in part because we
are very compassionate but if you fling
the doors open
you no longer have a country anymore we
already have
the most open immigration policy in the
world
if you look at the number of migrants
who've entered the united states in the
last 60 years or so it's the largest
movement of peoples ever in the history
of the world
so as compassion as we want to be you
might have to
you might have to dial that back a
little bit because
if all your focus is on people from
other countries foreign nationals coming
into yours
then you are disadvantaging people in
your own country and the
responsibility of a government
is to protect its own citizens and this
government is failing to do that
why are the migrant caravans coming now
is it because of some political event
that happened in their own countries no
it's because joe biden has lenient
immigration policies
so when you have tough immigration
policies you disincentivize immigration
during the first few months of of the
trump administration illegal crossings
plummeted
they started to tick back up after that
when they saw that actually the policies
didn't really have much teeth
trump talked to good game but he was
largely prevented from implementing his
tougher policies
joe biden is saying yeah the doors are
wide open come on in
and the migrants and more importantly
the people organizing the migrants know
that joe biden is going to be pushing
for a mass amnesty and the democrats
know that that mass amnesty is likely to
give them
many many many many new voters
so that migrant care is just going to
keep on coming and it's bad for the
migrants there's a lot of crime that
happens
there's a lot of injury that happens
while people are crossing that border
illegally
it's bad for them it's certainly bad for
the country but the democrats don't care
because they see a political advantage
in it
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]